J'ai attendu une éternité pour un
homme de ta force
mais un homme permanent a rampé dans sa propre
tombe à la recherche d'espoir un désespéré
les Turcs menacent de détruire mon royaume
ils sont presque là
je veux le pouvoir de sauver mon peuple
sauver mon  famille
ton
salut est dans le noir
et toute sa puissance bienvenue dans ta vie
tu auras la force d'une centaine d'
hommes
à quel prix tu n'as aucune idée
mais je vais te montrer à
boire
ce qui t'arrive
j'ai choisi ça
mais pourquoi parce que
les hommes n'ont pas peur des épées
il vient
ils ont peur des monstres
ce n'est pas qui tu es tu
penses que tu es vivant
parce que tu peux te battre
tu es vivant à cause de ce que j'ai fait pour
te sauver
le
monde
n'oublie jamais
qui je suis